so this was just shared
last week border patrol video showing
children being dropped
from border wall now watch it's a little
disturbing for parents
if you're watching this just just take a
look at this go ahead kai
took them all the way up to the wall to
the gear
look at that how old is that kid by the
way ricky three and five
oh they said it three and five three and
five look at that look at that look at
the one
boom how far is that drop six feet i
know oh no
no 14 feet holy moly it's like they're
dropping
uh dylan in one center oh my god from a
14-foot wall
look at the kid is still laying on the
ground yeah i think they dropped the
little one next i think that's the
five-year-old and then i think that's a
three-year-old if i'm a mistake
oh buddy or something like that or the
other way around
yeah and they throw whatever package
they gave and
by the way pat let me let me here's
here's the reality behind things and
then they ran
here's the right behind things this
happens every day they just happen to
catch it
this happens every day you know i live
four hours after no of course not
especially right now i live four hours
from the border i lived in mexico i went
to school in mexico
uh you know we're we're very familiar
with happens in mexico
one thing is to and by the way not by
and i mean this with all due respect not
by whitewashed mexicans that watch the
news i think they know right
we have family there we have family in
tijuana we have family at the border
mexicali yep we know what's going we go
visit there we go
our families the mexican families like
for ours our
grandparents doctors are there like
we're always there we
know what's going the mexican community
knows what's going on with the mexican
community
right so it to me it's interesting you
know not not not because it is your
rights
it is your right to have your opinion i
think it's very interesting when
non-mexican people want to have an
opinion on what's going on with the
border
when they have no family there no direct
connection no phone calls what's going
on
that you you know it's like me having an
opinion on the country that i've never
lived in
and then you know like when i want to
know about a certain country i ask the
person like i talk to you so she pull it
out
tell me about you know what's going on
in iran what happened you know i'll talk
to you about it you know
i don't know right and i could try to
read articles or like all i want
that are edited by somebody else that
has also no freaking idea on what's
going on
and think that they know what's going on
so you know the reality is this happens
all the time and
the mexican community we knew this was
going to happen we
knew it and on top of that it's music to
the to the cartels
it's music to their ears they said open
borders let's go
i it's it's it's it was a stupidest
thing ever
you know everybody wants to seem like
they're you know you know everybody
wants to seem like they're woke
and thinking that it was a good idea it
was a horrible idea
tell us why 33 of women okay so the
the most the more south you live over
the border yeah
uh the women are being raped and
murdered so 33 of mexican women
are being raped 35 are being murdered
after they're raped
okay so when they're coming up by
coyotes 33
of the women are being raped by coyotes
by coyotes
or of all of mexican women no no i'm
sorry migrants i'm sorry thank you for
correcting me thank you for correcting
me thank you for correcting me okay
thank you for correcting me the women
that are coming up to the border they're
being raped by the coyotes or by fellow
uh uh migrants okay and then
that number gets worse the more down
south you go for example if you get to
the states of chappas
cancun people that are migrating the
more south they come up
salvadorians are notorious by the way
shout out to salvador's i love them to
my
to my compatibility my close friends the
salvadorians notoriously
immigrant salvadorians hate mexicans
because when they're crossing they go to
guatemala and they get treated
normal they get into mexico they have a
rate
give or take of 80 percent of their
women being raped because now they're in
mexico illegally
so they have two options from the
federals uh federal the federal police
state police and the military can you
show the map so everybody yeah so they
can understand
the map map of south in south america
south america so what ends up
it's actually central america central
central america so so what ends up
happening is the
the the the these agencies are giving
them one of two options
either a you have sex with me or
i arrest you and i deport you so they've
already done the traveling see
there you have guatemala right you have
police el salvador
so if they have to go through they have
to go to especially salvadorians
so they go to guatemala they're cool
right because they're neighbors
but once they're coming from where
they're coming from imagine
are you trying to bring your kids or
your family to us you have to go to
guatemala so
so and you also got to go through mexico
right so what ends up happening
you go to el salvador right you go to
guatemala they have to go through mexico
but remember
the salvadorians and guatemalans are
entering mexico
illegally so once they come across
against a
across a law enforcement agency
mexico is corrupt so you have one of two
options either a this is going to happen
or b we're going to rush and departure
so that's why illegal immigration
hurts hispanics it hurts them
because our women are being raped and
and murder a lot of them are being
murdered
i have a girl on my team she's not she's
no longer with
us anymore she she's doing a different
career but she sat in front of me she's
like i have trust issues with my
boyfriend i'm like why
why would happen she was breaking down
she from el salvador she was 15 years 16
years old raped by five different men in
mexico
so it's like it's it's people like they
watch the news and
yeah it's we should open the border to
everybody you don't know the damage
you're doing to these people
and on top of that people seem to think
it's not just your uncle juan that wants
to come molans
it's the human traffickers the organ
traffickers the child traffickers and
sex traffickers
there's more people in trafficking than
there's people that want to come work
does that make sense so people only
think one category my uncle juan that
wants to come molans
no my boy behind him is six other
traffickers of different organizations
it's not just your uncle juan that wants
to come olans
does that make sense but the media will
never say that because they need the
votes
and mexicans typically hispanics are
very emotional
when you touch right and then what's
your excuse for me my parents came here
illegally
your parents came here illegally also
does that make it right
should i not care about these people now
that i understand how it works
should i just keep my mouth shut or
should i be an advocate for the truth
the truth is our women are being raped
and they're being killed and these kids
are being trafficked
they're grabbing kids and they're taking
the organs out of them and sell them in
the united states for people that are
dying old people that are dying that are
rich they can afford these organs
so it's like you just saw it happen by
the way that's one image
if the other video with the kid that got
the uh yes he they abandoned him yeah
that happens all the time none of this
is new but we know this have you seen
this
yes i have with the like 10 year old kid
who is the guy that found the kid can
you fast forward a little bit
the border control
might looks like it looks like a truck
it's a ford yeah more than like he's
gonna be uh
look at this body
[Music]
this happens all the time this happens
and we know it
the mexican people know it the ones that
actually sit there and understand what's
going on
that's why so many so many map so many
first generation
now first generation hispanics are
turning conservative and they're
because we're not sitting there in front
of univision listening to jorge ramos
talking about how evil the border is
we know what's going on the guy's just
turning a blind eye the idiot knows
what's going on
but of course you've got to get the
ratings up right you got to get the
ratings up by talking about what gets
people emotionally he cares about his
career he doesn't care about the mexican
people
it means a sellout let me ask you ricky
forget about just for a second the u.s
border because as i'm looking at the map
and anyone can see this right now if
you're coming from honduras or
el salvador that ain't a that in a
short walk
no brother to go through all of
guatemala mexico to go through mexico
city
to even make it to the border of texas
or california arizona
is a ridiculous trek so walk me through
the process of someone who's leaving el
salvador
because this is not a u.s issue at this
point this is a mexican mexican issue
this is a mexican here's a hypocrisy
ready here's the hypocrisy
the mexican president when the first
caravan came up from uh honduras
had the entire military at the border to
stop them it's funny
they talk about trump is bad and racist
because he wants to build a wall yet the
mexican government sent all the military
done to south mexico why doesn't mexico
build a wall
they have a wall in the south yeah can
you put up the vehicle
can you pull up the video where the
mexican military was
holding back the caravan mexican
military holds back the caravan at the
southern border
watch watch watch the hypocrisy okay so
uh
uh at southern border um let me see if
there's a
is there is there uh images let me see
okay
there it is the the go down all of them
all of them
but there's a border there they had
crossed that's the mexican military well
guatemala blocks houses for u.s
the hypocrisy the freaking hypocrisy
here we are met at the american
government but yet here's here's the
watch out with the channel watch out
with the channel so so here's uh
yeah right there like for example you
any of those pictures right there right
what are the monoblocks what am i
security forces what border is that
happening
the guatemalan border because remember
they got a guatemalan mexico
and then and then there's this isn't
even a u.s issue with this no it's
everything so at the end of the day
everything there's a mexican yeah more
than anything every country sovereignty
is being violated
not just the american one but of course
jorge ramos is not going to tell you
this univision
don lemon aoc won't tell you this
they're not going to tell you this so
give us some solutions that you think
because obviously it's a problem whether
you're republican whether you're a
democrat whatever you are
it's a freaking problem and whether it's
obama whether it's trump whether it's
biden no one's figured out the solution
give us the solution look in your
opinion here's
here's here's here's the reality behind
things
we the reality is this every country
needs to take care of their people
okay so maybe maybe to a certain extent
they got to get better at electing the
president and start being so emotional
the reason that this play like for
example the president of mexico amlo
he's a socialist he's a bernie sanders
of mexico
how do you get voted emotional mexico's
rich
so is venezuela by the way with oil well
they used to be but well they well but
they s with the oil
right so what ends up happening you got
to stop voting emotionally
you know a lot of people like to blame
america for the problems in other
countries
we didn't tell them to vote the way they
did right like maduro travis we didn't
create travis and maduro they created
themselves and then people voted for
them because they spoke nice
everybody likes to blame america for
other countries problems i have this
conversation with liberals all the time
oh venezuela's going to it's because
america no bro it's because of them
yeah i agree okay it's not our fault no
okay stop it
right i don't know who would think that
it's america's fault
many people are voting people i don't
know many americans who
brother know what the hell is going on
in the house many people talking about
what are you talking about you know a
lot of americans who are very
uh vocal on honduras elections there are
a lot of americans that say that's the
work of america america did that to them
yeah and that's why he says that's why
we have to take them right
so harmony ramas is on university he's
he's a doctor he's a dominant he's a don
lemon of he's a dominant what's his um
approval ratings bro they love him oh he
is uh he's like
he's i'll put it through this way i said
it the other day and i'm gonna tell you
guys right now
pastors no longer have uh uh priests and
pastors
no longer have power over the hispanic
people
you don't know who he is you know i know
who he is but so so
so now pastors and priests no longer
have power over the american j with the
j
what the yeah with the j jorge ramos
right this is this is this is a sellout
this is a sellout so
anyway here's a lot but um
latin americans love him the the old
school ones
the first generation like myself no
longer do so his approval rating amongst
our generation is going down
but a lot of people like him give us
some solutions back to the solution
so so the i don't know about i don't
know if there is a solution but here's
the reality behind things
people here's here's here's here's look
bro i lived in mexico likes i lived in
mexico
on school in mexico uh you know just
small periods when i was there with my
dad
okay people in mexico
they're gonna show you images of like
bad we could show you images of
people living in tents in l.a and make
it seem like that's the whole
the united states okay there's people in
mexico don't starve to death
people in el salvador don't starve to
death people in guatemala don't starve
to death that's just the truth
and some of the viewers may not agree
because they watch too much news okay
but they don't start i have family there
i have ants that are missionaries
that live in those countries people
don't start they're not about africa
hold on hold on hold on hold on
it's not africa they're not starving to
death because they still have social
programs because they have money because
oil
united states gives them money so
they're not starving they're you don't
see what kids
their ribs coming out you just don't so
the reality is the solution is
stay in your country so you can fix your
papers and then come so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye